hey there so our body requires 20 amino
acids for its daily metabolic process
but all 20 are not synthesized in our
body and hence we depend for few of them
on our exogenous diet that means we can
only obtain them from the diet now which
are the amino acids and what are they
known as so these amino acids are known
as essential amino acids but how to
remember which one are the essentials
and which one are non-essentials for
that devika is here with another trick
and the trick for today is to just
memorize the sentence any help in
learning this little molecule proves
truly valuable now take the first letter
from the sentence and this is the list
of your essential amino acids which
you'll remember forever if you like the
trick please like share and subscribe
our Channel